مع العناوين الرئيسية للحرب في الخارج
والتضخم هنا في الوطن ، قد
تشعر بالقلق والإرهاق أكثر
من المعتاد
، يشعر الكثير من الناس بالتوتر
ولست بمفردك ، وكلما
قل شعورك بالوحدة ، قل شعور هذه المشاعر
بالحياة  مدربة وخبيرة الصحة
ستيفاني مانزور لديها هذه النصائح الثلاثة لمساعدتك على
تقليل هذا القلق المتزايد والقلق
أقل من استخدام حواسك وشم
طريقك إلى الصفاء ، يمكنك إما
رش عطرك المفضل أو يمكنك
استخدام الكولونيا ، يمكنك إشعال شمعة
يمكنك  استخدم الزيوت العطرية مهما
كانت رائحتك تجعلك تشعر بالاسترخاء
وقليلًا من الراحة ، رقم اثنين عندما يكون
هناك الكثير مما يحدث خارج
عن إرادتك أو عندما تقترح الكثير من الأفكار في
عقلك أن تتوقف
وترشف شيئًا دافئًا مثل الساخن  الشاي
الآن لماذا الشاي الساخن جيدًا عندما يكون هناك شيء
ساخن علينا أن نبطئ علينا أن
نهدأ لكي نشرب ببطء
المشروبات الساخنة والثالث يتحول إلى
التنفس ، جرب أسلوب التنفس البسيط هذا
الذي سيساعدك على التخلص من
التوتر ، واستنشق الهواء لأربع تهم ،
وثبته في الجزء العلوي لمدة أربع تهم ، ثم
أخرج ببطء لأربع تهم أخرى ،
وهذا سيساعد نظامك
العصبي على الاستقرار أكثر ويشعر
بمزيد من الاسترخاء من أجل صحة اليوم  دقيقة
أنا ماري مالوني